live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show that is
dumb cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman number one best-selling author
ramsey personality host of the ken
coleman show is my co-host today we help
people build wealth do work that they
love
and create actual amazing relationships
so you've got questions about your life
your career your money we're here to
help open phones triple eight eight two
five five two two five caleb is in
charlotte north carolina to start this
hour off hi caleb how are you good dave
thank you for uh taking my call my
pleasure how can we help
so i'm in the middle or i guess i should
say the beginning stages of starting a
business
and i'm wondering if it is the best idea
to take any profit and put it straight
back into the business so i can keep
doing it debt-free
or would it be better to take the profit
and pay off personal debt which would be
because right now we're in the kind of
the middle stages of baby step two on
our personal debt
okay you got i currently have a
full-time job which is um
in addition to the business so the
business is separate okay
and so you can get out of debt on your
full-time job are you married
yes yeah why forecast at the home
no my wife is a stay-at-home mom we've
got a so what do you make of the day job
about 140 good for you okay how much
debt have you got
right now where's probably around
18 000
okay yeah stop your whining and get out
of debt really seriously 140 over 18
knock it out dude well
that's a new it was a big jump recently
so okay good i'm messing with you but
you the bottom line is your numbers are
fabulous you got a big old shovel and a
small hole
so let's just knock out that 18 and and
that's the good news now you got the
side business and you can afford to take
all the side business and pour your
money back in
uh out of that uh we're not borrowing
money for business
ever
you will ensure your failure if you do
for multiple reasons yeah especially in
a small business situation i mean this
is throwing off a lot of cash what is
the expense that you're thinking about
that you'd have to cash flow versus
uh going to debt
well it's not um so it's going to be a
baseball training facility um i'm
we'll be leasing the building so i won't
be in debt for for that um
it'll just be equipment and how fast or
how much equipment i want to start out
with versus you know just kind of
growing a little more organically yeah
organically stick with organic man it's
just you don't want to stress yourself
out and this i'm guessing is the dream
is this something you eventually want to
step into full time or you want to keep
it on the side
um
eventually i would like it to be um
full-time um
i baseball's kind of my background has
been for a long time and the job i'm in
right now i love um
but it may not be more than a 10-year
thing you know um so eventually i would
like it to be able to support my family
full-time sure well good then organic is
the way to go or else that dream could
become a nightmare dave's right you just
don't need debt on this and you're so
close here's a couple things yeah here's
a couple things caleb will be teaching
entree leadership on this when you grow
a business with actual cash you purchase
different things at a different speed
than you do when you use other people's
money
you're more careful
about what you buy and you're more
careful about what you pay for what you
buy because it's like real money
you know and that's there's a reality to
that uh the second thing that happens is
you it forces you to grow to make your
purchases slower and you're going to be
learning about the business you're going
to get what we always laughingly call
learnings uh which are mistakes
that leave scars and you're going to you
know you're going to learn stuff that
would tell you not to purchase something
that you might have if you've gone ahead
of
the learning
and the cash holds you back and kind of
keeps you by dealing with only cash it
keeps you from going ahead of what what
you've got to learn yet and so you don't
make us you don't you don't ma and then
the third thing is when we borrow
let me just here's the deal
i've been doing this business for 30
plus years
90
of my ideas suck
about
and this is a world-class
nationally known brand
and all of that all the 10 million
people that have gone through financial
peace university 22 million people
listen to this all of that impact
is because of about 10 of our ideas the
other 90 of our ideas we survived them
because they were stupid
yep and the problem is when you're going
for your walk in the morning or you're
running the morning or you're
sitting on the back porch with a cup of
coffee all your br all your ideas are
brilliant and when you put them out
there in the real world you just
determine that they're not and when you
borrow money
into the wrong thing you magnify the
size of the mistake
because you do stupid on steroids
and so when you use cash
it causes you to go at the speed of your
learning it you'll learn you'll make
better purchases and more careful
purchases and you don't magnify your
mistakes because there's 100 of the time
you're going to make mistakes it's
brilliant and one thing to add to that
caleb cash increases your innovation
because if you're borrowing money you go
i'm going to buy this equipment this
equipment because everybody else does it
and when you got to go cash you go how
do i teach the baseball swing or how do
i do this without a bunch of fancy
equipment it really does increase your
innovation because when you don't have
cat when you don't have the cash but you
still want to grow it you go how can i
do this
the least expensive way and the
imagination takes over and that's what
leads to innovation craic rochelle talks
about this at the time
the limited resources
when you realize your resources are
limited and everybody's resources are
limited but the borrowing of takes away
that effect temporarily but the limited
resource forces the creativity that's
correct and it forces you to get scrappy
and you scratch and you claw and scrappy
always wins
and uh the
some of the
more shameful errors we have made at
ramsey were when we got a little bit fat
and we had a little bit of cash we had a
little bit of room and we just went well
what is right there
and then all of a sudden
you lose that scrappiness you lose that
creativity you lose uh you know forcing
to learn the techniques blocking and
tackling goes to the side and we think
we're too good for it and um
you know
and and you're looking for an easy
button and there's just not a freaking
easy button that's right so you're
really doing a good thing here caleb
you're really doing a good thing yeah
you've got a great situation with a
great day job to pay off your debts and
to continue building your finances and
100 of the profits on that business can
go back into that business grow it
organically grow at the speed of
cash you know we built this building
uh three years ago four years ago
whatever it was uh
the only thing the newspaper actually
got right because they never get
anything right on me
um they make up crap when they want to
but um anyway they that ramsay is
building the building at the speed of
cash yeah and that was that was the
headline oh good and after you got past
the headline nothing in the article was
accurate but
you know like it never is right but
that's rare yeah an accurate headline
yeah but i mean that's it we are that's
what i told the lookout we're building
the building at the speed of cash in
other words we run out of cash we're
going to stop building
[Applause]
there you go
[Applause]
this is the ramsey shack
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman number one best-selling
author host of the ken coleman show
where we talk about career
and job
is my co-host today open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
nicky is in wichita kansas hi nikki
what's up
hi dave um
not a lot how are you today better than
i deserve how can we help
good um i'm calling because um
my husband and i we
own two houses well right now we're
we have a mortgage on one and
one um is supposed to be our rental
property we haven't been able to rent it
yet
um but it's the house that we lived in
when we got married four years ago
and um he's always had a dream to
rent this property
and he
he just really wants to rent it
and
i have a lot of conflict so we've been
trying to follow your steps since we got
married since before we got married
and he's the one who introduced me to
you
and
um
so we we paid off all of our debt after
we got married and we are still
debt-free
praise god
um
but
um i know that i've listened on your
show before and we've
been partially through financial peace
university and we've gotten some advice
from some of our church friends and
um
renting this house
doesn't seem like the right thing to do
right now
um
and i really don't know what to do it's
caused a lot of conflict it's like the
main conflict in our marriage
and
i'm just calling you to see what you
would advise me to do
okay um
hmm
well uh
i
i hear him whining in the background he
was always my dream and you're a dream
killer that's what i'm hearing
because the way you were shamed into
your into your sentence structure
uh i heard shame coming out i know it's
how he's always just dreaming i don't
want to kill his dream which means he's
been telling you that you're a dream
killer
and let me just tell you when you kill
somebody's nightmare you're not a dream
killer
you're a nightmare killer
and you know if somebody's doing
something stupid and you tell them not
to do it you're not a dream killer
that's an act of love
and so your disagreement is based in
love here it's not based in the fact
that um little boy can't get what he
wants um so let's not start there at all
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
dignify that with an answer but uh but
what what let's just back up a minute i
think the two of you need to sit down
with a marriage counselor and pan back
because basically he signed you up for a
serie a way of handling money that was
proven
that would be the shortest distance to
wealth and generosity
and then once he signed you up for that
he changed
horses
and decided anyway my dream i went a
rental house with dad and um so he's the
one that changed the deal here
so somebody has to kind of help you guys
navigate through
the mediation of
him changing the direction because you
didn't change anything
he said hey let's do this dave ramsey
stuff and then he goes well i don't
really want to do it anymore
am i missing something
no i i don't think so okay
and you sound awfully tired fatigued and
beat down by a stupid rental house
discussion
it's just a house
yeah
okay
i i will mention also that it's been in
his family
so
he has had his family let him know
that um
they would rather him not sell it
well then they ought to buy it and
yeah
i agree
you know and
okay there's so many guilt trips in the
i mean you guys you guys are good travel
agent for guild trips around there
him his family it's like a modus
operandi so you the two of you need to
decide what is best for the two of you
if it includes keeping this house and
paying it off very very quickly that's
okay
if it includes keeping this house and
staying deeply in debt because my family
shamed me into it and my husband shamed
me into it this is toxic as crud
this house is paid off um we completely
own this house we don't owe any money
well the one you're talking about
renting
right
right you got debt on the other house
yes the house that we live in we bought
in 2020. oh and you but you borrow money
on it because you didn't sell the other
one
right yeah so
so effectively you borrowed money to
keep the other one
yeah now what will the other one sell
for
um the rental yes
uh
well it's appraised at 45 000. 45 000.
yeah
well this is a fine piece of property
it's really small it's like a little one
bedroom one bathroom um house
most people call me with car payments
bigger than this
and y'all are arguing about a dump of a
house
oh lord what's the rent on that i can't
imagine it's
it's a piece of trash
there's no question listen 20 years from
now are you going to be glad you own
this as an investment no
it's not going to get better it already
sucks
no i don't want this piece of real
estate
no no no no no no no no no if you want
to keep it as a
is there land with it
no there's not there's nothing on the
value
no it's a town it's
it's a tiny house on a big lot
yeah um it has a and it's very very old
and very dumpy
yeah yeah
it's 45 000
girl this tells us everything we need to
know
okay so here's the deal i i don't care
but here here's the thing
the question you all have to ask
yourself as a couple
other people outside of your marriage do
not get a vote in this including me you
call me for my advice i'll give you my
advice but i don't even get a vote okay
you guys got to decide what you're going
to do and the question you need is the
two of you as a husband and wife need a
pan back and say 10 years from now 20
years from now which of these decisions
are we going to be glad we did i can
promise you having owned over 2 000
pieces of real estate in my life that
dealing with the tenant you're going to
deal with in a 45 000 house for the next
20 years is not going to add value to
your life
this is going to be a total pain in the
butt
and all for nothing financially the only
possible reason to consider keeping this
house is it's been in the family
and uh it's a 45 000 keepsake but even
then it's it's listen this is this is
one of those things that he needs to let
go of
and so yeah you need to you need to sit
down the marriage counselor because
the pain in your voice has nothing to do
with his property it has to do with his
family injecting themselves into euros
life it has to do with your husband
changing horses in the middle of the
dead gum stream and saying well you know
i'm yeah
but yeah take the 45 000 pay it down on
your mortgage and then start working to
get your mortgage off that's what dave
and sharon ramsey would do even if the
little house had been in her family or
my family and even if our little
families didn't like it we would still
go
check it out if you want to keep it it's
only 45 grand run yourself down to the
credit union write me a check i'll hand
you the deed
yeah and i think the marriage counseling
is the key here
this thing has become way bigger than it
needs to be it's just not worth it it's
not causing a ton of financial stress
other than the upkeep so i think there's
two sides to this i think dave you're
absolutely right but i also don't think
it needs to cause this much stress for
her either it's not like it's burdening
them it sounds exhausting it does it
seems like this thing has gotten huge
and it's a little teeny tiny house that
quite frankly they don't owe anything on
i would do the same thing and i'd take
the 45 now like today i'd take it yeah
and put it on the house
i'd take
35 well get rid of the problem it's not
a blessing it's a curse yeah yeah and so
it's i
it's gonna be a long yeah
there's a reason you can't rent it hello
[Music]
so yeah i i think there's the the
fatigue is not about the house it's not
about the finances it's about your
husband changing
horses in the middle
of the stream saying we were going to do
this now i decided i don't want to
and it's about all this interference and
argument over
really nothing
it's not worth it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of paycheck
purpose is my co-host today in the lobby
of ramsey solutions on the debt free
stage josh and ashley are with us hey
guys how are you
we're doing great dave how are you doing
better than we deserve brother welcome
where do you guys live
we're from burgesstown pennsylvania
which is right outside of pittsburgh
awesome very cool so how much debt have
you guys paid off
we had 147 500 that we paid off love it
how long did this take you it took us
nine years wow all right and your range
of income during that time
with overtime and bonuses we started in
the 80s and now we're between 100 and
150. okay way to go guys very good job
all right and what kind of debt was the
148 thousand it was our house hey
look at the weird people
wow no payments in the world how does
that feel it feels great
i can't imagine how old are you two
i'm 33. i'm 34. all right and you have a
paid for house that's right what's the
house worth
we bought it was worth 150 and it's hard
to say what it's worth now okay but you
bought it like nine years ago yeah so
it's probably worth four or five hundred
uh it's definitely up a few bucks at
this point so definitely okay you don't
even care because you're not selling it
that's right all right good way to go
you guys way to go so tell us what do
you guys do for a living
i'm an operations supervisor for a
midstream natural gas company i'm a mom
and a wife i love it very good good for
you guys household executive i like it
that works for me i knew you're going to
say that so the uh 148 000 nine years
tell us how this all got started how'd
you get introduced to this whole ramsey
stuff
so
before i was an operation supervisor i
was a instrument electrical technician
and i was on my way to a call out and i
was scrolling through channels and you
were on the college station and that was
the beginning of everything
okay so you heard us talking about this
on the radio that's right and you said
uh wait a minute maybe i could pay this
off
yep so bought the books and then uh not
too long after that we went and did fpu
oh wow okay all right so actually you
just were along for the ride or you did
you uh push back against this or was it
all your idea and he's just making it
like it is it was not my idea no
i am the free spirit okay um but i am
the first one to cut up my credit card
ah she wins that contest yeah there you
go okay i'll show you
so when he comes home and he starts
talking about dave and the show and all
this stuff and he paints the picture
what do you think it's gonna do for you
guys
how quickly did you jump on board at
least from okay this makes sense to all
right i'm gonna be the first one to cut
the card
um
i don't know i i think at first i was
even after i cut the card i was kind of
really frustrated with him over the
whole budget thing i can remember
our first two budget meetings i cried
oh wow
[Laughter]
was it the process that made you cry or
the
master there beside you the test message
oh oh honest to a flaw here we go
too much truth right here i like it i
love it that's fun that's fine because
that the first budget committee meetings
are emotionally
they're gut-wrenching
because you're a you're having to look
at all your stuff
and it's like man did we screw up some
stuff and man if we got some opportunity
to go win here and then you got to start
going ah man we gotta cut back and i
gotta watch this and it's all your fault
and man you can have some of the biggest
fights of your entire marriage in those
first two budget meetings
and uh that's a very real thing that's a
very real thing so did you guys push
through here you are nine years later
and boom house is paid for
was it worth it it was totally worth it
yes
yeah will you go back in debt no that's
not the plan at all
my favorite part i think is the piece
part the financial piece part
i think that's my favorite part you do
kind of relax in a place you didn't even
realize was hurting
you know and you go wow i thought i
didn't realize i was carrying around 300
pounds until i set it down
i i you said one time that
that
some people have a security organ and i
tell him all the time i have a security
organ
absolutely it's very real and um yeah
financial peace two words that don't go
together like airline service you know
it's uh pretty incredible well i'm proud
of you guys what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
the budget was
huge but it was a it was a crazy ride
through the end the last year was just
pretty wild um
we started off on a pretty paved surface
uh we had uh just had baby number four
and then i got promoted and i finished
my bachelor's degree all right and we
work for i work for an awesome company
we say we because it's a package deal
but uh
we had just taken six weeks of paternity
leave paid for so
very cool stuff what's your what what'd
you get your degree in uh engineering
management oh wow very good so
but we came back off of uh paternity
leave and uh we found out that uh
ashley had stage four cancer
also
so we didn't even do a budget for about
four months while we were working
through the early stages of that but we
had been so disciplined and used to
doing it that uh
we knew what we could spend
we had an emergency fund
we had our family our friends our church
and our work family taking care of us
and supporting us and we were able to
keep on going and then uh
things started turning around there and
then
very unexpectedly we uh lost my dad in
january so wow
it's a tough run on the end there you're
right how are you doing now actually i'm
good um
i will forever always have treatment um
but
it was actually i say this and people
kind of look at me weird but like it was
actually really cool
there was a period of time where i
didn't get out of bed
would you say like six weeks thereabouts
but i never thought that i would get to
be where i'm at now i'm kind of back to
where maybe not necessarily back to
where i was before but
close to back to what it was before wow
yeah wow it's pretty cool it's a great
recovery yeah praise god good stuff okay
really cool
i like the end of this story better yeah
and so to tout the plan if you really
want to test your uh financial game plan
get cancer and see where you're at on
the other side yeah so that'll uh
that'll ch that'll check everything out
for sure wow
well what an incredible story you two
you're amazing we're proud of you well
done well done excellent excellent job
all right bring the kiddos up we've got
a copy of baby steps millionaires for
you how ordinary people built
extraordinary uh extraordinary wealth
and now you can too and of course you're
gonna uh that'll be the next chapter in
you guys story we've also got a uh
additional membership for one year to
financial peace university maybe give
that away since you've been through it i
don't care go back to it good for us
either way and uh total money makeover
is there for you to give away as well so
all those gifts what are your new kids
names and ages
go ahead
oh we can't hear them you're going to
have to sir
she's nine
this is caleb he's 5.
lc she's 7.
and levi's 18 months all right very good
all right josh and ashley and the gang
from pennsylvania i love it 148 000 paid
off in nine years making 80 to 150 count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two
[Music]
ready one two three
[Music]
[Applause]
some help in the countdown yeah little
levi had had another idea there was like
wait a second i want to say something i
got something to say here
well done
well i'll tell you what life is going to
happen to you
anyway that's the truth so you might as
well
be on a plan to prosper while you're
doing it
and put yourself in a position to uh not
have to worry about money while you're
fighting stage four oh my god i mean
that's amazing she came back from that
really true that's pretty strong peace
allows you to
focus on what you need to to persevere
but when you got money problems and then
life throws the extra problems at you it
only compounds and this is a wonderful
example of that that's exactly right
that's how it works i mean this idea
that
you know it's that forced gum thing one
less thing to worry about it's true it's
uh you got to really have a whole way a
whole different way of viewing this
stuff and
um this freedom gives you every bit of
that proud of those guys they're heroes
man
took control of their life
nine years the struggle goes on but
they're 100 dead free
house and everything and the other side
of a cancer fight wow
this is the ramsey shot
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman number one best-selling
author and host of the ken coleman show
ramsay personality is my co-host today
you know every time you hear someone do
their debt-free scream it's because at
some point they said enough i'm not
living like this anymore i've had it
you have to have that moment where you
say that's it enough
and when you get mad like that
that's when you're getting ready to
change your life
inflation stupid credit cards gas prices
it's killing you
and you it may be your time right now to
rise up and say enough you know you have
to decide to control what you can
control and that's you
your behavior you have the power to
control and change your future
financial peace university is where we
have shown 10 million people how to do
that
and it's a proven step-by-step plan and
you want to get out of debt get on a
budget build wealth be outrageously
generous learn about investing it's the
class you should have taken in high
school but you didn't
so now
it's time to be sick and tired of being
sick and tired say that's it i've had
enough
i'm done
go to ramseysolutions.com
enough
dot com slash enough and get yourself
into financial peace university bill is
with us bill is in san antonio except
that's not the line
there it is bill's in san antonio hey
bill how are you
better than i deserve sir how are you
just the same how can we help
okay so to keep it short i am 28. i'm a
software developer with a household
income of about 5 000 a month my wife is
25 and as a full-time grad student
we are on baby step three so we're
completely debt free however we are
currently cash flowing my wife's final
year of grad school so we don't have
that much saved
uh here's my question
i'd like to go back to school myself and
change careers however to a career that
would pay significantly less money than
i'm currently earning
i'd like to pursue pastoral ministry it
is a passion and a calling i felt for
over a decade
and i've been deeply involved to local
church since
throughout the time
however i'm very deeply concerned with
how i'd support a wife and any future
kids we might have on a pastor's salary
so how do i prepare financially to be a
minister with a family
hmm
lots of pastors i know make sixty
thousand
and more
yeah
i think you've gone for it
what are you worried about specifically
um
how much how limited we would be whether
we'd be able to
pay for home or
for our kids
college expenses in the future
um
if we're only making 60 or something
close to that you're making 60 now you
said you made 5000 a month
right but we don't have any kids right
now
and we don't
and we're only renting we're like we
don't have
significant expenses right now well uh
bill let me give you a real life
scenario here um
i just uh over the weekend was back in
the hampton roads virginia area visiting
my mom and dad for my brother's uh
daughter's wedding and just reveling in
the living room late uh on saturday
night with my mom and dad about 47 years
of ministry
my dad recently retired he never made
more than 40 000 a year my brother and i
both went to college my mom and dad have
paid their house off it's been paid off
for 20 years
it's a false narrative that you can't
raise kids
and help send your kids to college by
being a pastor and my dad pastored small
churches so
um you know your income ability uh in
multiple positions within ministry
multiple okay
can easily make 60 and i think dave can
make the case that you can do everything
you want to do for your family with your
family making 60.
i'm just giving you a real life scenario
that's really helpful
yeah i know that the the compensation
could be extremely variable i talked to
one pastor was making as little as 30 or
35. um okay hold on hold on hold on hold
on what was his scenario what was his
situation
uh he was a full-time pastor in
philadelphia of how big of a church
that i don't know i can guarantee is
very small
so you're choosing the extreme edge here
um to kind of validate your fear
and if i could just challenge you uh
this is what you feel called to
and if and i'm not gonna question that
but if you believe that you're called to
ministry then you also believe that god
will provide what you need and at some
point you're gonna have to uh
choose faith over fear you know this you
can preach
absolutely
and um yeah
and two other
pieces of information
eighty percent of people in um
in america today that our pastors are
bi-vocational
they work two jobs
and so your days of uh being a software
engineer probably not over
i know lots and lots of pastors uh
financial peace university has been
taught over 50 000 churches now
so we've got an intimate look at
the finances of the pastors the finances
of the churches
for three decades now and the vast
majority of them make over sixty
thousand dollars a year uh in a church
of you know reasonable size but if
you're gonna pastor 45 people
or a hundred people you're not going to
make any money
but if you're going to grow a church and
have a ministry that has some impact on
you know a larger number of people than
that then you're going to get yourself
in a position reasonably to make a
decent income and anytime you want to
add to it
then you can um just you know pick up
some software development stuff some
software engineering stuff and you've
got that skill set the second thing i
would add to this is
um education is always not always
education in your chosen field that is
applicable continued personal growth
is always a good idea
and so a pastor who continues to study
doctrine theology
greek hebrew and so on uh is a good idea
throughout the rest of your life
uh but there are many movements in
within the evangelical circles that do
not require a degree at all to pastor
i know many many pastors of substantial
churches who are great theologians who
never darken the door of a seminary
except to go speak to them occasionally
and so the requirement to have a
seminary degree in order to be a pastor
is simply not there in the marketplace
that you're in is it preferable that
you're knowledgeable you bet
i would add to that i think you ought to
go to israel and actually see where the
bible happened and walk around on those
spots before you preach a sermon it
would really change the whole world for
you i did i did that late in my faith
walk and it changed everything in the
way i read and saw the bible and the way
i teach the bible and so yeah you know
there's a lot to the whole thing of
gathering up information and knowledge
in your faith but the requirement of an
expensive seminary degree to make 35 000
a year is simply not real that's not
true
so you can start pastoring now
and you can add your formal education as
you go along and
you know if you pick up an extra 40 000
bucks on top of your current income and
start pastoring now by vocationally then
start adding some classes in grow your
ministry over time you're making 60 100
it's not that unusual at all you're
ministering to 500 or a thousand people
uh not that unusual at all and uh that's
you know that there's a whole lot of
need for that in america today
and uh for men women that do that kind
of thing so um and yes seminary is a
good idea i'm not trashing education i
don't do that but but you know one of
the things you talk about ken is is it a
requirement to enter the space and the
answer is no here it's not and and
realistically you know you need to be
thinking about what is my entry point
because there's lots of different ways
you could go i will tell you unless you
have a specific heart to plant a church
meaning to start a church from scratch
which let me just tell you that is the
hardest thing in the world to do let me
just tell you it is
my dad did it twice
but you may serve yourself well by
getting in on a staff and and learning
ministry from a terrific leader above
you and and and taking your time to move
up so a lot of this right now needs to
be where do you see yourself 5 10 15 20
years down the line in ministry is it a
para church organization which is just
as much ministry as a traditional church
these are the questions i'd like you to
figure out right now by hanging out with
people that are doing
ministry in those roles and then you'll
get verification on where you want to go
and then the best way to get there yeah
if you could get on staff somewhere now
you could contract your software
engineering and work i think that's a
cool type of idea working as a full-time
job yeah it'd be very possible
yeah a lot of options there dude a lot
of options a lot of ways to get at it
thanks for being a listener thanks for
calling in this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status simple choice we
help people build wealth do work that
they actually love and create real
amazing relationships
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and host of the
ken coleman show is my co-host today as
we answer your questions about your life
your money your career jump in and we'll
do just that the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
alex is with us in houston texas hey
alex welcome to the ramsey show
hello gentlemen thank you for taking my
call sure what's up baby i'm in babysit
too and i would like your advice on
whether or not i should spend money for
a financial coach the coaching fee for
the coach i'm looking at will be 250 a
month and i bring home 2 000 a month i'm
pretty strong on the head knowledge i've
been listening to you guys for a couple
years now but i'm really struggling with
the 80 behavior part and uh keeping
consistency and i would like your advice
on what you think i should do no if
you're making two thousand dollars a
month i would not spend 250 a month on a
coach
that's too much as a percentage of your
income
have you noticed alex that your income
sucks
it does yeah i definitely
want to find uh a way to increase my
shovel and um you are uh
right in line with the with the facebook
group i i put a poll out on there and 90
92
gave me a no don't do it 82
maybe you need a new job doing
statistics oh my gosh
yeah what do you do what's your income
what do you what's your career i i work
in a factory a food production factory
and um
interesting part of my story i'm less
than a year fresh out of prison and i'm
just trying to rebuild my life together
and make up for some bad decisions that
i've made in the past and
part of that is trying to find a career
where
i will be given a chance but i can also
be paid for my my worth like what i can
what i'm capable for and uh what would
that be
forget your record right now what would
you be pursuing if you didn't have this
pass that you knew you were going to
have to navigate around
yeah
what would you do what would you do what
do you want to do i love working in
restaurants that's one thing but it's
not long term and stable i really would
love to be
a real estate agent and and to sell
houses i really like working with people
um that would be something that i think
i would be good at sales in general i
think i'll be good at because i was
really good at it in the restaurant
industry yeah i made good money doing
what i did
and um i would love to go into sales so
here's the thing um we are seeing coming
out of the pandemic and i want you to
actually do some research on this i
think you'll be surprised at what you
find there are a lot of companies around
this country that are really truly
reaching out to people with a criminal
record they're non-violent and and
things of that nature and they really
have proven that they've entered into
society and they've paid their uh
they've paid their dues
and they're looking because we have such
a huge gap right now with 11.3 million
jobs this last job report out of july
11.3 million jobs available 8.3 million
people unemployed and i'm just telling
you you'd be surprised at some companies
that are willing to give men and women
like you a chance that's one thing i
want you just do your research and see
what's out there second thing
whether that was a true piece of data or
not
relationships relationships
relationships people are going to see
your story and you get to an interview
process and you tell them that you've
got a record because you're an honest
guy and they will still shoot you down
right there but the reality is is
through relationships
people that you know who know you and
know that you're a good dude and know
that you have paid your debt to society
and now you're trying to do what's right
they are going to be the key to you
getting where you want to go and i'm
going to tell you something if you want
to get into real estate
you just got to find that one or two
people who say you know what i'll be
your broker i'll put my arm around you
i'll develop you i'll pour into you i
believe in you because the reality is is
people will buy a house from somebody
that is kind that is knowledgeable and
helps them accomplish their dream of
getting that home they're not doing a
background check on you so i'm just i
wanted to just put that in your heart so
that you know you actually can get where
you want to go does does texas real
estate law prohibit a felon from getting
a real estate license
that's something i need to research um
definitely i don't think it does not
sure i don't think it does it will keep
you out of the securities business
you're not going to be a stock broker
or a financial advisor another another
realm of sales might be better for me
yeah
but the uh but real estate
i i most states do not uh have that as a
prohibition on a real estate license
and uh so how long have you been out
i've been out since october of last year
so i'm coming up on a year good for you
okay
and how old are you
28 years old okay cool
cool
well you're you're you're up for a fresh
start i love that yeah and um you know
if i'm you uh
i'm gonna move towards sales because of
some kind because you're a people person
you're articulate and you can make more
in 20 minutes in sales than you're
making now
yeah yeah i don't know what you're
selling at this point you know in this
discussion but i i think you've got some
opportunity there uh and you know real
estate is a tougher one to get in
because it takes longer to start making
money other types of sales you can get
and you make money in the week
and real estate sometimes it often takes
six months uh you know to get the
on-ramp going
and um you don't really have that kind
of margin but no i would not spend 250
out of 2000
uh for a financial coach financial
coaching is worth every penny but you
know you can't you know you're not in a
position to afford that right now you're
not making enough money
so i want to work on the shovel size and
some other things in the process and
what we'll do is we'll put you guys put
you through financial peace university
as our guest and that'll help you with
the behavior side as well
but you're learning a whole lot of new
things about self-control and about
behavior and about you the guy in your
mirror in this stage of your life
you're you're coming through a whole
process there in every element of your
life so if i'm you i'm plugging into a
great church i'm gonna get some strong
uh emotionally mature uh
men in my life if i'm you that are older
than you that'll walk beside you and
coach you and give you opportunities and
connect you to their buddies and say hey
you know here's alex he needs a shot
and uh and they'll walk with you and you
can meet those kinds of men in a good
church
and uh you need those kinds of folk in
your life right now and then get in this
class but no i i'm i'm not gonna tell
you i mean we've got several thousand
ramsey trained financial coaches across
america that are worth every penny that
they charge they're wonderful they're
absolutely incredible but no i would not
tell somebody making two thousand
dollars a month to spend 250 a month on
that that's not a good play not a good
play at all
there is um
something that has to happen almost in
dr john delony's realm
when you go through something like that
to get that in your past there's the
reality that he faces of you know when
he applies he's a felon right that's
right there's a reality a background
check whatever all those kinds that's a
reality there but the other thing is is
it
you you have to redefine yourself
say i am not defined by my past
i'm informed by it that's right and so
i'm not a guy i'm not a a bankruptcy
i'm a guy that filed bankruptcy 30 years
ago
and it informed what i did in the
following 30 years yeah
told me what to do and so but i wasn't
defined by it i was informed by my
idiocy
and so there's something that has to
happen when you go through a big
life-changing setback like that that you
have to reset your head to go forward
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show thank you
for joining us america we're glad you're
here ken coleman ramsey personality is
my co-host
this is the deal
how many times do you find yourself
saying one day
about a goal that you've had you know
one day i'm gonna be in a career i like
one day i won't have to battle anxiety
anymore one day i'll buy a house one day
i'll be out of debt one day sally may
will be out of my life
well stop waiting around on your one day
you've got to do something about causing
it to happen
uh you have to turn uh dreams into goals
and goals are basically vision with work
clothes on
and so you're gonna have to get with it
here
stop waiting around smart conference is
oddly enough the one day event where we
tackle all areas of your life and guys
let's face it we could use that kind of
boost out there right now you're going
to hear from the nation's top thought
leaders on money
career
mental health relationships marriage
leadership and it includes
craig and amy grochelle pastor from life
church on marriage
dr john deloney number one best-selling
author on mental health rachel cruz
number one best-selling author many
times over on money george campbell from
the ramsey networks
ken coleman number one best-selling
author on the
issues of career and finding a job that
you love from paycheck to purpose
christina ellis new ramsey personality
on board i'll be speaking it's a
day-long smart conference it's only 39
the vip and platinum are already sold
out the event will sell out early and
get your tickets now this it's in dallas
it'll be coming up really quick in
october the 27 on october the 22nd
saturday it is a day-long event for them
you pay 39 to see any one of these
people speak
and have gotten a deal but you get the
whole day you're gonna leave exhausted
and smiling and smarter that's why we
call it the smart conference that's how
it works
blinds.com gives us our question of the
day find out for yourself why blinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window coverings with free
samples free shipping new promos they
run all the time use the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible deal
today's question comes from thomas in
nebraska i have 15 000 in student loans
6 000 in a car loan and a mortgage my
current job will be paying me 100 000 by
2024. is it too late to get into the
finance field with having to go back to
school for a master's in finance i will
most likely have a drop in pay and my
finances are based off of making six
thousand dollars a year but do not know
60 60. so what did i say you said six
thank you dave that would have been
really strange okay uh i do not know if
being in the financial field will pay me
that much in the midwest what should i
be aware of before making this change
well the first thing thomas is we need
to get this debt
out of your life you're not making any
kind of change
uh as it relates to going to get a
master's degree
with this debt in your life so we want
to get you debt free
it's not too late
at all for you to get in the finance
field but i would really question why
the master's degree
again i'm not anti-education but
we know that you can do this research on
your own most master's degrees do not
have a great roi
and in this case for you to get into the
financial field you do not have to have
a master's to be successful in it so i
would have you identify where you want
to be in finance and then having
done the research and then speaking to
men and women who are winning in that
particular area what is the best path
for you to get there
because i don't buy the notion
that you're going to have to have a drop
in pay either i don't know
it should absolutely be or it's the
wrong place in finance yeah you should
have been an increase in pay and
virtually no
finance jobs require masters
there's virtually none
i mean there's a few you know corporate
gigs or something where you're trying to
move up into upper management or
something like that immediately step
straight in they're going to want to see
a master's but um
the truth is is that uh finance is
simply that not that complicated
one i mean if you're a math person and
you get into it and you learn the
process and you learn the formulas you
learn the critical thinking skills um
you can do you can be a financial
analyst i mean or do finance or whatever
form that takes but when you say i want
to go into finance dude that's like
saying i want to go into sales
yeah what part i mean there's like nine
bazillion possible jobs right so you
need to figure out what type of thing
you want to go into then you can start
figuring out if it really involves a pay
cut and if it really needs further
education i doubt it does
i doubt seriously it does
um
but again there's a few corporate jobs
that like to have an mba with a
specialization in finance that wouldn't
be unusual uh but a master's in finance
is just simply not required to be in the
financial field i mean we work with
financial people that are
brokers that are uh you know sitting
down with you helping you with your
investments uh we work with financial
people in the mortgage world we work
with financial people in the uh
insurance world we work with financial
people in the financial planning fields
uh very very very few of them have
masters
and it's just simply not a barrier event
that's right and very very few of them
make less than what you're talking about
so yeah you've also got a bad
information there so i think you need to
get in to figure out what part of the
world of finance you want to go into
and then figure out what that pays
and figure out a way to get in that and
maybe if you want to work on your
masters
maybe the new job in the world of
finance will pay for it
and that would be the way i would do it
but i just i'm gonna
you know
this is like
like you've got a
i don't know cold feet where you are and
you just want an excuse to get out
yeah i think here's the deal when when
people think about changing they
automatically think what education do i
need i think that's the right question
but you've got to classify education a
little bit differently than we used to
20 years ago now in this particular
areas dave is laid out you're talking
about certifications and some training
that's it
it does not require a master's and uh so
hey what do i need to learn where can i
learn it what's the most affordable way
to learn it those are the specific
questions yeah where do i get the
knowledge base that's correct to operate
efficiently that's what you're looking
for francis is with us francis is in
richmond virginia hi frances how are you
hey i'm doing great thanks so much and
great responses to ken and alex i really
appreciate it i'm an ordained clergy
person and um
as ordained clergy i have to pay my own
social security and medicare taxes the
church doesn't pay for that and to
offset that we're allowed a housing
allowance that is tax free
my wife and i have a home that's well
our household income is 150 000 we have
a home that's valued at 520 and we have
110 000 left on the mortgage that's 3
out of 15 years on on that mortgage we
have about 50 000 in our brokerage
account and we're set on retirement
we're really good there our question is
do we want to take that 50 000 out of
that brokerage account and pay down that
uh that mortgage
when we pay the house off though my
taxable income will go up and so that's
kind of the rub that we've been
wrestling with a bit
your taxable income will go up correct
because my mortgage is part of the
housing allowance no it's not not
taxable no it's not and so no no no no
no no i i i've had to teach pastors this
all over america okay you need to go you
need to go sit
you need to go sit down with a tax
professional that knows what they're
doing on the pastor's housing allowance
the the belief that is an absolute lie
all across america is that if a pastor
pays off their house they lose their
housing allowance no the tax law clearly
says that you can still write off the
market value of rent of that 500 000
house
right as if it was a tax as if it was a
house payment you do not have to be in
debt to get your housing allowance
no i no i did i i do understand that but
my actual taxable income will go up when
the mortgage drops off because it's
actually the the fair market value
rental furnished or your actual expenses
each month whichever is lower and so for
our home it would be the actual expenses
which would be lower and so
my housing allowance is going to drop
significantly which means your fair
market value furnished rental on a 500
dollar house
that's high that's high and that's the
only thing you got left if you got no
mortgage
yeah right exactly so you can you can
still take that as you can still take
that as your housing allowance you're
not going down you're going up
you've only got 110 000 mortgage left
so i no i i think you pay off the house
as fast as you possibly can you take the
fair market value furnished of a 500 000
house
and that's your housing allowance you're
still gonna come out ahead
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage jeremy
and kaylee are with us hey guys how are
you hey dave we're better than we
deserve i love it where do you guys live
uh we live in a small town of less than
3 000 people chaffey missouri it's two
two hours south of st louis okay cool
welcome to nashville so good to have you
guys so how much debt did you pay off
we paid off 125 000 in 56 months good
for you and your range of income during
that time oh we started in the 80s and
we finally broke a hundred we were 104
this year finally yay what do y'all do
for a living i'm a school nurse and i
work for a tow boat company construction
on the river oh wow good for you very
cool very cool so what kind of debt was
125 000 um it was everything from cell
phones uh a credit card van
transmission transmission for the van
and then student loans and our house you
paid off your house we paid off our
house wow look at the weird people how
old are you guys i'm 35 and i'm 40. and
you have a paid for house yep what's the
house worth about 125 and i love it and
it's completely yours yup no payments in
the freaking world no none how does that
feel nice not bad
56
months you did this
wow all right so tell us the story
what's got all this started and what got
you so fired up you plowed all the way
through and finished the house um well
uh i'm the one that drank the kool-aid
first my best friend asked me to go to
financial peace with her
and jeremy works 28 days away
and i said well i don't have anybody to
watch the kids no they have daycare and
she talked me into it and i was like
fine i'll go
and
the very first class when you had the
kitchen table um we were doing fine at
the time but when you had the kitchen
table in the video and you talked about
how um
you know
your family where you have as a family
becomes piled with bills and stress we
had lived that before
and i felt it like i just felt it and i
felt the chains and i was just like nope
we're not living this way
and whenever you're the first person i
ever heard say you don't have to have a
credit score because that's all you're
told is you have to have good credit you
have to have good credit to have
everything
and
um
i was like we can we can do this like
this is something that we can do um and
so
i told i came home from that first class
and told him about it over the phone
and he
and i was kind of skeptic at first but
he was a great guy i would have been i
come home and i leave home and see what
you get yourself into exactly gone for
four weeks not
again so when you available back off the
road off the river and went to the class
immediately you were in yes we were on
board okay just like that well and i had
the benefit of he's gone for 28 days so
whenever he was like i don't know about
this i kind of threw a tantrum and i was
like no we have to do it together you
have to do it as a team
um i just paid stuff off while he was
gone so when he came home
i was like but look what we've done
already and he was like oh my goodness
we are smart
absolutely
and so that also helped get him on board
that's a new one dave you've probably
heard it all but i've never heard of
stealth debt payments that's the right
one yeah okay we are we are really smart
look what we did while
while you were gone yeah
well that that'll get you some buy-in
because it's not like he's like oh i
hate this let's go back in debt he
didn't say that so no sir no here we go
game on after that though absolutely
yeah i do want to say something about
the credit score though when i was 18 i
tried to get a car and i remember i went
to a car lot and the car salesman was
like well you're you probably have no
credit and it's really hard to get a car
with no credit
and they ran my credit and i had bad
credit because a family member
put a phone bill in my name when i was
like 15.
that's awful
and
i hated credit i hated the credit score
because it wasn't my fault it was like
it was like
it was like
a bad grade on a test you didn't you
didn't take herself yeah for real
that's the worst kind of violation
it really is and a family member
so you had to get all you had to get the
identity theft
cleaned up is what it amounts to
and and the worst part is the thief is
in the family
so
i was like game on i was like if i can
we can live without a credit score let's
do this
yeah
i like it when they tell me i have to
have a credit score and i say you don't
take money exactly
because i got money is that does that
work here
[Laughter]
so that journey when i hear it's like 56
months yeah that's a lot of months what
kept you guys going
each other
each other in the debt free screams
um
we had a couple date nights where we
sent the kids to grandma's and we'd push
the couch up to the tv so it was a
bigger screen because it's only a 40
inch
only yeah
and
we would uh just play devry screams back
to back to back and hear everybody's
stories and you can relate to people and
that's why we wanted to be here because
we're like there's a family out there
there's somebody that's been through
going through what we've gone through
been through
and you know the pandemic everything but
the house was paid off so it was an
inconvenience for us you know
and um i was actually an office nurse at
the time and i was sent home from work
and
and i even had to draw unemployment for
a few weeks and as a nurse i never
thought
i would face something like that so
um they send you off the river during
the pandemic i was actually on the boat
uh during my trip when it really started
getting a little crazy but uh i came
home for my two weeks of course because
i'm just tired of seeing everybody's
faces after four weeks but uh
i come home and when we come back we
just took a you know took a covet test
took a swab and all and
just kept working back at it sir yeah
all right
cool i figured i figured good good for
you guys well done hey that's cool
cool and you get the other side of it
and now you've got no payments in the
world none it's a whole different place
to be
and uh so did you have more cheerleaders
or more people thinking you were crazy
um we had very a few close close
cheerleaders that understood maybe two
that actually knew what we were doing
and why a lot of people thought we were
crazy laughed at us
but that's encouragement that's
encouragement we're gonna because we're
gonna do it and you're gonna
wish you did yeah it's the uh toby keith
thing how you like me now exactly there
you go
yeah
well done you guys i'm proud of you
you're amazing thank you very very cool
very well done all right what do you
tell people now that you did it the
secret the key to getting out of debt is
um life's gonna happen life happened
uh just keep at it yeah we had lots of
medical happen in for four and a little
over four and a half years i mean
it's inevitable the excuses you just got
to push through it like anything else if
you want to do it decide it make a plan
and do it yep yeah don't let anything
stop you
you got to push through all the stuff
because there's always going to be stuff
yeah yeah that's good that's good that's
inspiring well done you guys well done
all right bring the kiddos up we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story
how ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too we've also got a
one-year membership to financial peace
university and you can go through the
class if you've never been through it or
give it away if you'd like same thing
for the books and that includes the
total money makeover book which has now
helped over eight million people and so
i'm gonna send all of that with you to
say thanks for coming into nashville to
do your debt free scream we're honored
to have you guys what are the kiddos
names and ages um this is connor he's
11. and priscilla she's nine eight she's
eight okay well she'll be nine soon it's
okay and uh you know you guys have
completely changed your family tree you
realize that absolutely because for four
and a half years these guys have been
watching every move you made
and they'll remember that time you came
to did this weird thing in nashville
called a debt-free scream and that's
when mom and daddy changed everything
and that's when we started becoming rich
around our place
you're on your way we ask him
yeah what are credit cards and what's
the first thing hanging up bad that's it
that's the answer what's a credit score
something someone else needs
exactly
not me i've got money they take that
here congratulations you guys all right
jeremy and kaylee connor and priscilla
from the missouri area 125 000 paid off
in 56 months making 80 to 100. count it
down let's hear a dead free scream
three
two
one
we're debt-free
[Applause]
man they push through 56 months
that's rowdy
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of paycheck to
purpose is my co-host today open phones
at
825-5225 chris is in duluth minnesota hi
chris welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thank you for taking my call and
great show thank you
thank you sir can we help
so my broker uh recently advised me to
consider investing in what he called a
unified managed account a uma
delaware research but i wanted to get
your expertise and opinion on this
okay what is your net worth
um
probably just under 2 million and how
much have you got how much have you got
under management with a broker
i've got
about half
about well
it's all under his um about
five hundreds in our 529
and then the remainder about half is in
our roth and our my tsp
and the other half is in an opening
account so there's about 700 he's
talking about putting in that
account
okay
all right well i mean there's a lot of
people using managed funds
in the world today a lot of our smart
vista pros use those and basically you
know you're usually talking about one
one and a half percent a year of the
balance and then they're managing the
funds and you can do away with all of
the commissions and fees by doing that
and
it it is not cheaper
but it just gives you some flexibility
uh and some you know some you can move
stuff around without any tax issues and
that kind of stuff
typically that's called a managed fund
the only time you use a uma a unified
managed account is if you're wanting to
screw with single stocks
and bonds and some other stuff in there
i only do mutual funds as you probably
know chris
and so managed funds will do that
with a with a uh you know an investment
professional and most of them are using
almost all of them are using those now
um i still buy all day shares because i
i just buy and keep forever and i don't
really do any moving around much but the
managed funds is a
is a very popular way to handle it now
and there's nothing wrong with it
it's slightly more expensive over a
10-year period
if you held the same exact amount of
money for 10 years or same exact funds
for 10 years but it's not it's not
prohibitive it's not a ridiculous fee
and i would say you're getting ripped
off or anything like that it's not uh
the thing that scares me the only thing
scares me about it is the fact that we
put unified in the name here which
usually is high net worth individuals
which you are
and it usually is where you want to
screw around with single stocks in the
portfolio and i'm not a player on that
if you're going to play with a small
amount of single stocks in there you
know maximum of 10 of your net worth is
what we say that's fine if you want to
do that i personally don't and i'm a
little bit worried that this guy's
wanting to
pull you into some of that stuff are you
hearing any of that are you just doing
mutual funds
i well we're worst
of that 700 i would say only like a
hundreds and in like two or three stocks
so
we're definitely in the state like
there's four or five mutual funds that
we got across there his his point is
that that taxes are
what we have to start considering when i
retire in 15 years
and and so our plan is is that we spend
this down first and then the tsp and the
roth
the roth tsp in our roth we spend down
when we're our 80s i would agree i think
that's i think he's got your priorities
right on that yeah okay and so he was
like he's like this is a statistic i
don't want to use this but he says the
tax efficiency the watch rules the tax
laws uses all this and he says he said
it's actually
very similar to a mutual fund it's just
how
it's managed is what he's saying
well i
i disagree with that but
from a tax standpoint it is and i think
his suggestion is fine
uh what i just don't want to see is i
don't want to see you with 700 000
screwing around with single stocks and
you're jumping in and out trying to play
the market and basically day trade
inside this account uh you're going to
lose your butt if you get off into that
hole okay so we you don't don't do that
let's just stay let's move more and more
towards just managed mutual funds inside
this account but the advice he's giving
you is correct i don't disagree with a
single thing he's saying
based on the way you're the context
you're giving me around it um but
sometimes people use that same tool
for
high risk speculation
rather than
calm steady investing you follow me
i do i do i've been with him 20 years
we're a buy and hold and that's why
we're so i mean i don't make much i only
make a little over a hundred that's how
we got to this point by
dollar cost averaging exactly well he is
right about he's right about the tax
efficiency that's one of the benefits of
it and the fees are not outrageous and
it sounds like you're doing this in
context yeah i'll probably go ahead and
do it
okay
okay
when then we lost the cell phone
dropped the cell phone into the bathtub
okay but yeah it's uh
net worth just went down but yeah right
hey what a great what a great story
though two million dollars of net worth
and has killed it for a long period of
time and backs up what our study showed
the largest study of millionaires he
didn't inherit it he doesn't have a huge
salary makes good money but it's not
it's not great 36 of the millionaires
one-third of them never made over a
hundred thousand dollars yeah and uh
that that's he's one of them yeah
beautifully done
very beautifully done tara is with us
tara is in texas hi tara how are you
hi good thank you dave for taking my
call sure um
so
i am recently divorced
i have two girls at home that are in
high school a senior and a freshman
my bring home pay right now is around 85
000.
i have about six thousand dollars
between in debt between credit cards and
orthodontist uh payments and little
things like that
i've got forty five thousand in vehicles
between my daughter's car my car
and a three-year-old home that i built
in 2019 that i still owe 275
000 on
so obviously recently my income changed
we went from about
a 225
000
a year income to just mine which is like
i said 85.
i started your program recently uh i
just
i sold everything that i could i
completely purged my house
and got my thousand dollars saved up i
just started uh tackling some of the
debt but
you know i built this whole spreadsheet
and when i look at the big picture i'm
kind of like
okay i know those vehicles are gonna
break break that down for me on the cars
what is your car what do you owe on your
car
so i owe 32 421. okay
what is your car worth
it's a it's a brand new
uh challenger and whenever i got my
divorce i was stupid and i went and
bought a brand new car
it's the divorce stress car okay
and you're so your daughter's car is
like a 12 000 car
yes 12 000 908 is the uh balance on her
honda and what's it what's it worth
it's a 2017 with 55 000 miles on it i'm
not really sure okay you can look these
up on kellybluebookkbb.com
so uh if you're asking me what to do
um if the dumbest thing you ever did in
the stress of a divorce is buy a car
that you couldn't afford well you're a
pretty smart gal
because i've done a lot dumber stuff
but i think we can look at that car in
the driveway and go this is the one
thing that doesn't fit in the rest of
this picture the rest this picture looks
pretty solid calm under control wise and
then there's the challenger
right it needs to go
yeah
for two reasons one is it's financially
irresponsible and the second reason is
every time you look at it you're going
to feel dumb
right
it's it's a shaming car it shames you
when you go out there to get in it
am i wrong yeah
no you're you're absolutely well i have
bought stuff or done stuff financially
that was dumber than a rock and every
time i see the thing it reminds me i'm
stupid i don't like those things
right
yeah i'm getting rid of this thing it's
a reminder of the divorce and a reminder
of the pain a reminder of you making a
bad decision in the middle of the pain
and i don't need any of that and i don't
need 32 000 worth of debt on a car when
i make 85.
right exactly let's get you a
conservative 15 000 car and let's get
you and your daughter's car paid off the
other car paid off and if you had no
payments but this house payment your
life would be pretty good right now
okay so that was going to be my next
question about the house because house
is not out of control it's fine
if you like the house if you want to
sell it fine but if you like it it's not
out of control
it doesn't sound like it anyway if
you've got it financed reasonably hang
on we're going to put you through
financial peace university and
participate in your healing
after the divorce you've gone through
it's very very painful thing i'm sorry
you've been through that kiddo hang on
we're gonna sign you up for the class if
you'll take it i'll give it to you for
free this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show we help people
build wealth do work they love and
create actual amazing relationships
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five
five two two five ben is gonna start us
off this hour in winston-salem hi ben
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave again how are y'all
better than we deserve brother what's up
man good to hear hey i just wanted to uh
make it brief uh i just wanted to ask
you my company well my wife and i has um
briefly got to babysit four five and six
and uh had a question about investing my
company matches six percent
and then my wife's company matches three
percent on our 401ks um i guess what my
question is the nine percent
from my company that they don't that
they don't match and the 12 percent of
my wife's company that they don't match
should we take that um remaining
percentage and go with the smart
investor pro or just keep it within our
company 401k
okay the rule of thumb is this match
beats roth
beats traditional
so you do all the matching you can do
then you do all the roth you can do
and if you do all of that you're still
not to 15 then you would do traditional
does either your wife or your company
offer a roth
401k
yes sir both uh both companies both of
them they're both currently in a raw
401k good very good okay so you're going
to take the full match there obviously
and the match portion the portion the
company puts in is technically not roth
it's uh technically traditional you
can't do anything about that but the
portion you're putting in is roth now
are do you feel like the mutual funds
that you can select from in both 401ks
are good strong selections that you can
get good funds there
well i'll be honest with you dave i
don't know a whole lot about stocks
mutual funds um but i guess that's why i
was asking um okay i i'm really not sure
okay i'm not sure what's a good mutual
fund and what's a good stock
well if you can get in good mutual funds
at the work then it will be as good as
doing a roth ira with good mutual funds
with a smart investor pro the beauty of
doing the smart vista pro might be in
your case though that you get a teacher
in your corner that that smartvestor pro
will be have the heart of a teacher to
teach you
about your mutual funds and that'll help
you select the ones that work as well as
the ones for the uh the roth ira so i
probably would do at least uh one roth
ira with a smart vester pro and then
have them give you some advice on where
to put the rest of it whether you can
put it in the 401k but you got to put
enough in to get the match in both cases
and then you don't have to but that's
what i would do
and then i would do roth from there and
you can either do roth with a smart
visitor pro or roth in that 401k and
you'll definitely be able to get to the
full thing at that point so great job
great job man very very well done that's
beautifully played
you know uh
can this this money thing and this job
hunting
thing and this mental health thing the
stuff we deal with on the show all the
time
um
there's something about those three
different subjects there that they have
in common that they're
uh they're intimidating
you know it feels like you know i'm not
i'm not a mental health expert i'm not a
career expert i'm not a money expert so
i don't know what to do with my own life
and those things
and the good news is is that while the
subjects
you know they always have experts around
those three things
but the um
uh they're common sense the the
solutions are common sense that's
correct just common country wisdom yeah
it's these they feel very complex and uh
what the key to complexity is there's
always simplicity i always think about
it you know if i ever got out in the
garage which i shouldn't be doing much
with machines no no you should not and
you see all that uh that trimming wire
all tangled up well there's only one
solution to that right either throw it
away or you slowly start to unravel that
and oh you're talking about your weed
eater oh yeah yeah that stuff gets all
tangled up that's not a there's not
complexity there anymore it's simplicity
to get it untangled and untangling your
financial life untangling work
untangling your mental health all of
that has a simple solution and it starts
with hey how much of me is involved in
this and what can i do what can i
control and that's what we teach here is
a clear path in all of those areas to
say all right i can
fix this it is fixable and when you
decide that then you look into it you go
what's the best way to fix it and you
realize it's
usually much simpler than you think but
the fear and the doubt associated with
these heavy topics
tend to keep us kind of
oh just on the edge of moving forward to
actually make a change you know what too
that goes with that is um
it's a human tendency and you and i
share it with all of our listeners too
that
um when something like that feels
overwhelming or complicated or like over
my head then what i want to do is i just
want to hand it to somebody who says
they're an expert yes
and walk away and let them handle it
because i don't want to screw with it
um
but the the that very seldom turns out
well
instead what you need to do is you're
the experts that are in your life like
the bible says in the multitude of
counsel there is safety and that doesn't
say the multitude of experts true it
says counsel yeah counsel is teaching
yeah council is speaking into and then
you're
so what we always want to do at ramsey
with any of these subjects is we want to
give you information
and if we connect you with someone
a mental health professional
a uh a smart vester pro
churchill mortgage we always are
requiring them to be ramsey trusted on
the other end and have
this uh
heart of a teacher because we always
want you guys to make your own decisions
and so if you can't make the decision
it's because you don't have enough
knowledge yet
and you need to get knowledge in those
areas so that guy's question was
fabulous yeah it really was because now
he says i don't know much about this
but i need to go to a smart investor pro
because i think i need to know more
about it that's exactly right instead of
i you know but don't don't tell me i got
somebody managing my money no no no no
you're managing your money
they're
teaching you about how that's done and
helping you with that yeah or you know
i'm gonna i turned over my job search to
another guy yeah no no you're in charge
of your job that's correct here's how
that'll play out with that caller you
know he's going to now sit down with the
smartvestor pro and he's going to
understand his investment portfolio he's
going to understand the strategy he's
going to understand the things that
you've taught us over the years that
you've taught callers the rate of return
how you stay in the long game he's going
to learn all that and here's what's
going to happen he'll never be a
financial expert like a smartvestor pro
but because of that counsel that
advising here's what happens he's not
going to get freaked out and get scared
when the market dips for three straight
months he's not going to make risky
moves why he has a knowledge base and
now some wisdom if you know what's going
on
you sleep at night that's correct if you
don't know what's going on you're
wondering if your guy down there is
screwing you that's true it's hard to
sleep at night but when you know what
you know and you made the call then you
can put your head on the pillow
it's not a problem this is the ramsey
shop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
right now you're hearing a lot of the
talking heads the news stirring up all
the fear about the real estate market
the market's going to crash the market's
going to crash the market's going to
crash let me help you with this it's not
going to crash
sorry spoiler alert uh we have way too
many buyers chasing too few homes it's a
pretty simple supply demand equation
i know the economy sucks right now i'm
aware of that i tried to fill up my
truck the other day and it maxed it out
but those stupid stupid things stopped
before it let me fill it up yeah you
know i'm taking too much yeah i know
it's a big old truck but yeah it's a big
tank but gee mini
yeah you know here's the deal huge
supply of homes in 2008 not enough buyer
demand this is not 2008 it's quite the
opposite here so we've done the hard
work of vetting agents if you're in the
real estate market you're thinking about
selling it's actually a good time to
sell the market's not white hot like it
was where you get 38 offers in three
minutes
uh but you're going to be able to sell
the house in a normal marketing period
of time these days
pretty cool
and great time to buy a house because
the market's slowed down a little bit
you're not having to compete with 7 000
other people trying to buy the same
house on the weekend
so go to ramseysolutions.com
agent
get with one of our endorsed local
providers they're ramsey trusted and you
need a good real estate agent a great
real estate agent in your corner to buy
right now and especially to sell right
now if you're thinking about selling
this is the perfect time kids went back
to school
everybody's starting to think again
about this the vacations are over from
the summer
uh yeah great time so go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent and you can find the real estate
agent in your area
that we
recommend
clement is with us clement is in tampa
florida hi clement how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
hey i just want to say it's an honor to
talk to you guys about today um i was
approached by
a lawyer from canada
about a person with the same last name i
have who deceased a while back roughly
nine years ago
and they approached me saying that
there's there's some money left behind
an insurance policy after he died
uh roughly 13 million dollars and um
they approached me saying that hey we
wanted to tap into that and you can be a
beneficiary one thing we ask is that we
give 10 percent to
either local charity or a church of your
choosing and then we would split the
remainder 50 50. i want to know if um if
this is a common thing or not or if i'm
getting scammed and you're getting a
scam question
yeah it's a scam
oh
no there's no such thing
as an insurance policy where a lawyer
gets 50 of it for finding you
not in not even in canada
i don't know why that got me so good i'm
sorry not american yes there's just no
such thing clement i mean that's just
that's complete bogus crap
the person of the same name you don't
even know a relative you don't even know
never even heard of them you had no idea
you knew anybody in canada
you yeah you don't
you know
and so and the next thing is they're
gonna want some money from you up front
to get this all settled and figured out
yeah because you got to pay the upfront
fees to get the documentation done or
some crap and that's where they scam you
but there's not a you know
sorry i
i hate to burst your bubble but
uh there's a nigerian prince also that
wants some help getting his money out if
you haven't heard that one it's very
similar
um yeah that that's there's just not a
there's no such product out there
there's no
uh process in the legal system and
probate no lawyers of any kind that do
probate law
take half
for distributing an inheritance that
they had nothing to do with they just
don't do it there's no such thing
do they demand what you do with the
money like give ten percent of it that's
what i always get that the scammer with
a heart oh we want you to give some of
these well i used to give the thing
credibility right
yeah possibly yeah he didn't say he was
going to get half of it he said i i
would be liable to pay him half after i
received the full amount
yeah it's it's a straight up this is a
standard scam procedure
and um you're going to have to put the
money up somewhere
and at some point before you get money
and that's when they're going to take
you uh they're going to it's it's you
know
so no
as a matter of fact
if i were you i would report this to the
fbi
huh
okay because i'm pretty sure this is
going on quite a bit and you know this
is this thing's coming
waves but i'm sorry i wish you were
getting half of 13 million dollars i
wish that for you out of the blue from
nowhere but i can there's nothing about
this that doesn't smell like a scam i
would waste no time on it and for sure
don't give them any of your banking
information don't give them any card
information don't give them any
any further information on you that they
can use to trap you into some kind of
corner later because this is what
they're after here
and uh and they're gonna be persistent
and they're gonna make fun of you and do
all kinds of things and what you need to
do is just get away from them as fast as
you can this is a bad deal here
[Music]
yeah i just don't know what to say i
i mean wow
that's pretty bold well they do it all
there was one i'm trying to remember how
they did it it was the spanish lottery
and it came out of canada too and it was
a standard scam and i don't remember the
process on it it was called the spanish
lottery and they would call you up and
say you won the spanish lottery and i'm
like i didn't know it was in it right
and so yeah buy a ticket but then you
had to you had to post the money
in order to prove that it was you and
then they would switch it around and
then by the time they switched it around
your part never came but they took the
part that you put in and it's it's a it
was a
a process i can't remember the details
of how it rolls out but it's very very
interesting so um yeah check it out open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five
two
you jump in calvin is with us in canada
oddly enough hey calvin you're not an
attorney in canada are you
no i'm a real estate agent okay
entrepreneur got it cool how can we help
uh i'm looking at starting a business
i'm wondering how i can do this without
a credit score i would it's going to
cost me about 500 000 to get off the
ground and it's a advertising company
it's going to cost me i wouldn't do it
that much you wouldn't do it nope
i wouldn't go a half million dollars in
debt to start a business
okay so how would you go about starting
an advertising company where you're
building costs for each billboard poll
is about a hundred
but you can get that paid off with a 20
margin in two years
hypothetically
there's a rule in business
everything takes twice as long as you
think it's going to it costs twice as
much and you're not the exception
and so you've run a pro forma out on
some kind of best case scenario here
that's got you dreaming and you're
willing to take an unreasonable amount
of risk to get into this this is a story
that ends up in bankruptcy here brother
i've been doing this for 30 years and i
i started this business on a card table
in my living room and we've grown it to
300 million dollars in volume in revenue
this year with zero debt along the way
but it took a little while how would you
go about building this take a couple
years to save up the money to pay for
these polls and cash yep yeah yep buy
fewer of them
and boy when they start cash flowing
without any debt against them they're
going to cash flow like bandits if they
do what you're supposed to what you
think they're going to do how do you
think that it is out for about 11 000 to
pull
that's not bad what do you make now
uh right now i'm making about 150 to 200
i've been in uh as a i've been a real
estate agent for about a year cool so
buy five polls a year
50 grand
well the the polls i'm looking at
building they're a bit larger a bit more
permanent and that's why you can charge
more for them i thought you said you
could own for 11 000 a poll
no no a hundred thousand poll they
they'd earn you 11 000 a month
oh oh oh 100 000 oh really i just wonder
calvin how did that industry do when
your prime minister literally shut the
entire country down
i mean they were still i'm not too sure
i've been looked into those statistics i
know that right now all of the areas
around calgary the companies that are in
it are expanding currently okay yeah
it's a highly speculative business yeah
[Music]
i'm not borrowing 500 000 to start
buying advertising calls dude i think
you're gonna i think you're gonna you're
missing some parts of this business that
you haven't considered i can't tell what
it is in a three-minute radio call but
uh that's the answer to the question i
would save up and buy one and then save
up and buy another then i'd save up and
buy another and if you're making as much
money as you think you're gonna make on
them you're gonna cash flow your way
into a whole bunch of them within five
years
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're glad you are here
open phones a triple eight eight two
five
five two two five
eileen is with us in connecticut hey
eileen how are you
hi dave how are you better than i
deserved
i'm a first-time caller but i listened
to you for a long time well thank you um
how can we help
i am going to turn 59 and a half
and i was thinking of paying off my
mortgage with my tsp something
cool how much is your mortgage um
um 82 000 how much in the tsp
730 000. great do it
do it okay yep so you got to make it on
600 000 with no debt
life's rough right and i have another
roth outside the psp too
you killed a girl you're a millionaire
what's the house worth
320. i told you you're a millionaire
wow you're so proud to hear that
you ever thought about it i mean you add
up what you what you own minus what you
owe and if it's one million or greater
you're a millionaire
yeah yeah i thought about it yeah hard
to believe it took a while but yeah well
i mean this is what you've been doing
what'd you do for a living right
post office what'd you do at the post
office
just a clerk inside you know
just a clerk millionaire
right i started at what thirty thousand
and this is the high point sixty nine
thousand but i've been there 35 years
you're single
yeah well i'm divorced yes there was a
divorce in the middle there how long you
been divorced in one
oh 15 years okay
and one son he's 22. yeah
yeah so you can do it hey um i want you
to go look in the mirror because you're
pretty impressive woman
oh
okay
you're dead millionaire as a post office
clerk shut up this is this is amazing
it's freaking amazing
yeah you did good
you did good i'm kind of
kind of a nerd yeah
well you've been the tortoise so long
you forgot it was impressive
yep you're steady you're predictable yes
right and all those all those nights you
wondered if you were going to make it
when you were going through this divorce
right now they all paid off
yeah you made it a little nerve-wracking
you made it you made it you did it
that's great to hear that i mean i mean
you're 69 years old you get 600 700
thousand dollars with a paid-for house
after this conversation 59.
i want to say 60 years old 59 60 yeah i
mean yeah yeah close enough i mean maybe
59 and a half to do this but yeah
ding ding
thank you
yeah what do you tell people that
they're secret to be in a millionaires
ah you just gotta be disciplined and
just you know every week it just
automatically goes in
and
that's it what kind of uh which funds
did you use in the tsp
the c
cs9 mostly c though yeah so you've been
following our stuff for a long time
a long time yeah how long am i
oh
15 years or more wow you're a baby steps
millionaire
yeah my son listens we have to go on
rides to vermont and i'd have you on in
the car so now he's he's very
money savvy
good
good to have a 22 year old this money
savvy they don't live in your basement
that way
oh no he left yeah he's out west yeah
well very well done what are you going
to do to kick up your heels and enjoy
your life now
i don't know i haven't subsided yet
three to five years i plan to retire so
we'll see you like the trouble
yeah yeah
what kind of car do you drive
a subaru five-year-old use subaru okay
all right when you retire i want you to
get a good car
a better car
okay a nice car you're driving a you're
driving a car like a post office clerk
not like a millionaire
you hear me i want you to enjoy a little
bit of this money
and i want you and i want you to be
generous with some of this money so i
want to hear about some kind of like
cool trip you did
like you went to switzerland or you rode
a cruise ship down the danube or i don't
know what you want to do what is it you
want to do you need to go do that and
you need to get you a little better car
and just drive around the big old
millionaire smile on your face
okay
i'm so proud of you hang on i'm gonna
send you a copy of baby steps
millionaires since you are one
now that's fun ken coleman uh it's
really fun because you could literally
hear the light bulbs going off multiple
times you turned the light bulbs on in
multiple rooms of her head there it was
like oh okay i am awesome and i was
disciplined
that was really sweet really sweet to
see that and and she's been through it
you know and yet she stayed the course
really exciting i want to know what car
she's going to buy that that's kind of
funny you'd have to literally convince
her to do it oh i'm gonna take her the
dadgum lot i'm trying but you have to
drive her up there drive her up and go
you're getting this one right
but yeah because you know it's one of
the things that
those of us that uh you grind and you
grind and you hustle and you grind and
you grind and you don't even look up
yeah that's right and then when you look
up you go oh look at there right and
then you you have to build a new muscle
yeah and that's the muscle of enjoying
the money it's true and being generous
with the money at a different level
than never before she tells you
your emotions are still functioning
down at one level but your money's up at
another level right well you told her
you said she said i'm a nerd you said
well you've been a tortoise so long you
haven't noticed and she she's already
crossed the finish line she didn't
realize she won the race
she just kept her head down she crossed
the finish line right and she just keeps
on going and for the next three to five
years she's going to stack more money
yeah
you know because that she hasn't paid
for house there's about two i was
telling a group of business leaders of
the day i'm they're i'm a turtle on a
fence post
if you ever see a turtle on a fence post
when you're walking down a country lane
you'll know two things
one is he didn't get there by himself
that's right
it's the truth and two he's a bit
surprised
what am i doing here
and uh yeah that's that's the feeling
you have when you when you cross over
that apex on your wealth building you've
you've been pushing the ball the rock up
the hill for so long when it finally
goes over the hill you're like oh god
what do i do now i didn't even
this actually worked yeah oh my gosh
it's true and that's a standard emotion
of how do i stop and be generous how do
i stop and
enjoy and you don't have to be you don't
have to become irrational i don't want
to go buy a 200 000 car
but she sure does need a 20 000 one
um and out of 800 000 or a million
dollar net worth now and that kind of
thing so what a wonderful wonderful
thing so
here's what i want um
we need to somehow bottle that call
and
for the the group in america that's out
there saying you can't make it in
america today
we need to remind you that a postal
clerk just called here yeah
making 35 to 69 000 through her working
lifetime and became a millionaire by 59.
we need to remind you people the little
man can't get ahead
the rich just keep getting richer and
the poor keep getting poorer wealth
inequality is not fair
let me tell you what the fair is the
fair is where the tilt-a-whirl is and
the cotton candy is
that's what fair is
what's fair is that woman put money into
her tsp and didn't go out to eat while
your butt was down there stuffing tacos
and you and then you want to go when you
can't share let me tell you what's not
fair it's not fair that you want some of
her money and you just let this
president raise taxes on her
tax bill just went through they raised
taxes on her
that's not fair
joel now you're getting me excited i
mean really and so this is this crap man
and this idea that you know this country
is so broken that people can't get ahead
that sweet little lady there that's true
just work steady worked hard work
discipline worked consistently she had a
life
she didn't live in a cave and collect
lint and only come out on triple coupon
thursday but she was diligent she was
intentional and she became a millionaire
by 59
and then you call me up and tell me it
can't happen in america again kiss my
butt
it can too it absolutely can i talk to
these people every day
every day everywhere i go and i can't
stand it when you hope steelers out
there in the name of your leftist agenda
keep telling people that this place is
so broken that you can't win hey we got
our problems but we're the still the
best shot you got if you're the little
man in the entire world
america's still the best shot for the
little man in the entire world that's a
statistical fact you morons this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today first peter 4 10
each of you should use whatever gift you
have received to serve others as
faithful stewards of god's grace in its
various forms
tony dungy says it's all about the
journey mine and yours and the lives we
can touch the legacy we can leave and
the world we can change
for the better
truly one of the nicest people on the
dadgum planet that guy is incredible all
class now no question about it greg is
with us greg's in rhode island hi greg
how are you
good dave how are you better than we
deserve what's up
thank you guys for taking my call long
time listener first time caller so i
appreciate it
um i'm calling with a question regarding
whether or not
it would be a good idea for my wife and
i to sell one of our cars
okay
why would you do that we
um well we are moving in this fall to
tennessee and um we currently have two
cars
and um due to the fact that we sometimes
commute to work but we have jobs that
have allowed us to go fully remote once
we move so we're no longer going to need
the two cars
so to avoid the
expense of shipping one of them we
didn't know if it was worth it given the
market and knowing that
we're planning on having kids within the
next three-ish years um we'd be wanting
to get another one at that point so um
what are the cars do you guys think
uh so i've gotten a few estimates on the
one we're looking to sell and if we went
through a dealer and sold it to them it
would be anywhere from
nine to eleven thousand but if we tried
to do it private party i think it would
be a little bit more than 11.
okay do you owe anything on these cars
no they're both paid for what do you
guys make
we make around uh 180
uh 185 000 household income okay
um i would keep the car
until you make the move and get settled
in the new life
and make sure you don't need it
it's only eleven thousand dollars if you
get to tennessee and you're doing the
home work from home thing and and you
settle in the rhythm of that for a few
months and you go really one of these
cars is kind of stupid sitting here then
you can dump it then
but uh let's let's test your theory
against real life first
uh it's because it's not enough money to
matter in your situation
okay yeah
the other side to it i don't know if i
mentioned but we are in baby step two
and we have about fifty eight thousand
left in debt to pay off
um
but
we've been we started a hundred what's
the other car
uh probably just a few thousand more
than that maybe like 15. your cars
aren't your problem you were just you
just had to get organized with your 180
000 income and start knocking the 58 out
right
yeah yeah we started actually paying
down the 120 in november of last year
and now it's down to 58. way to go
so yeah you know so by you know what six
more months you're done at that rate
yeah i think our estimated payoff is
something like uh end of february or
beginning of march what i was thinking
yeah very good very good and if the
shipping an 11 000 car is a problem just
drive it
true yeah just drive it down here and
you know
then you're in tennessee and
i i if it was you know a bigger
percentage of your income or a bigger
percentage of your debt if it was a
bunch of money as a ratio somehow yeah
i'd probably dump it at that point i
mean tell me the car's worth 50 grand
yeah i might dump it you know but it's
11 000 and your situation with as much
money as you make i wouldn't it just
doesn't move the needle mathematically
and so i i personally keep it drive it
down to tennessee park you know get your
life settled get yourself out of debt
and then you go i don't need this car
sitting around then you get rid of it
but it's not really a math it's not
really a
a financial necessity that you do that
or a math-based need
tom is in grand rapids michigan hey tom
welcome to the ramsay show
thanks dave how are you doing today
better than i deserve what's up
so um
uh this is a question of integrity i
paid off about sixty thousand dollars in
debt and i have just a few thousand left
three thousand on a credit card that i'm
99 sure that i did not
um
that i did not take out this credit card
that it's like an identity theft type of
thing
have you paid on it before
no i have not you not paid a dime on it
no it was on the very it was on the very
end of my debt snowball when did you
find out about it
um
about like
nine months twelve months ago why did
you not report it as identity theft then
because i'm not 100 sure about it and
when i contacted the bank
huntington bank to get the
transaction history
i spent about a year trying to get the
transaction history and they they won't
give it to me so because they won't give
it to me i have
no idea
if i actually took it out or not so i'm
not comfortable yet going to the police
and filling out
a criminal report for a crime that might
not have happened okay i'm a little bit
confused about how your life operates
where you don't know if you spent three
thousand dollars or not
yeah yeah it was it's from like five
years ago is when it was taken out and
it was taken out alongside of another
there were two credit cards taken out in
my name one was certainly me the second
one i'm 99.9 sure wasn't me
so this puts me in a place where my my
my question is if i find out that it
well i guess it doesn't matter if it was
me or not the integrity thing is
i should um i should just pay it off
it's my name i should be responsible for
my name you're not responsible for
identity theft
not morally not under any definition of
integrity
there those people are bank robbers
you're not responsible for them robbing
the bank
so then
it sounds to me like you're leaning
towards the option that i'm
my integrity is trying to tell me to
lean away from and that's what the banks
you have a wrong definition of integrity
sir
if someone else robs a bank it is not
your job to make the bank whole that is
not integrity
they robbed a bank someone robbed a bank
of three thousand dollars just because
they used your name to do it doesn't
make you liable
um i think you're feeling guilty for
being so disorganized five years ago
that you're not even sure if this is
yours
no no it's not a feeling of guilt at all
it's like a thing of uh
i think that our country lacks integrity
and i think i don't disagree with that
if you told me you if you told me you
had uh
if you told me you
had taken this loan out i would tell you
to pay it as a matter of integrity but
you didn't take the loan out is what
you're telling me i mean 99.9 is kind of
like a hundred
okay well let me give you just a just a
real brief back story at the time that
this happened i was living in a really
bad area of town that was overrun by
gangs because i was house-sitting
a house for somebody
for my church i didn't realize that
that's where i was getting into at the
time but that's what i ended up getting
myself into but i'm the one who made the
decision
to go and live in that bad area and
while i was in that bad area i'm pretty
sure this identity theft thing happened
i think that's where my guilt is i made
a bad decision because of the bad
decision that i made it cultivated you
lived in an area where people robbed
banks
one of them robbed a bank
that does not make you responsible
for robbing a bank
because you lived in an area where
people rob banks
if you'll think of this as a bank robber
it'll help you work through the ethics
of it
yeah i hear what you're saying but it's
not okay dude go pay the bill if you
want i'm not paying the bill if i don't
owe it i'm not i'm done arguing with you
yeah okay but that
is it not a little fishy dave that he
calls the holder the bank of the credit
card and says this is me and i'm getting
bills for this i want to see the
transaction history and they won't share
it with him that seems a little squishy
weird to me well that's yeah it is weird
something's not adding up and then he
feels like he's got to die on this hill
here so i
and how do you 99.9 the 0.1
i
i think he's 100 sure that he didn't
take it out i think he is
i think he's 100 sure that he didn't do
this but he still feels like he has to
do it for some reason i don't know where
that's coming from
it's it's it is not an integrity issue
listen if you call this show and tell me
you don't want to pay a bill that you
owe i'm gonna i'm gonna be all over your
butt for integrity okay i do it all the
time and i have for 30 years but when
someone steals your identity you are not
responsible under any scenario for that
just because you lived in an area where
identity thieves live
i mean
if you live in canada and there's an
attorney there in canada that's trying
to rip somebody off on a 13 million scam
are you liable because you live in
canada no you're not this is just that's
just absurd
this this was that hour for sure that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you